I for one think we should be grateful to
Nvidia for the 4060 TI I mean sure we've
waited over a year for a card that's
only 10 faster in rasterized games and
and were they didn't upgrade the eight
gigs of vram from last gen but at least
they didn't downgrade it like they did
with the memory bus and it's it's just a
hundred dollars more if you want the
other eight gigs
seems totally reasonable when nvidia's
cost is somewhere between 20 and 35
dollars at least you won't have to wait
months for the drivers to get good okay
that last one wasn't sarcasm though
there is legitimately a fair bit to like
about the RTX 4060 TI It supports all of
nvidia's latest Ray tracing and AI
upscaling bells and whistles it's much
more power efficient than the card that
it replaces and it supports av1 encoding
which is a huge deal if you stream to
YouTube but you also shouldn't pull the
trigger without getting the full story
here there's been a lot of talk lately
about how eight gigs of vram just isn't
enough anymore and I've got some bad
news
it's not FUD at Max settings but only
1080p resolution The Last of Us remake
gobbles up a whopping 8.9 gigs of video
memory meaning that with an 8 gig card
some of that is going to spill out into
your system memory which significantly
harms performance or even worse if you
have an older system and not even that
old just one that doesn't support
resizable bar there is no overflow you
simply will need to turn down your
graphical settings and this isn't an
isolated problem we didn't test Jedi
Survivor for our suite today but that's
another recent game that is reportedly
using up to 10 gigs of vram at 1080p
epic settings
yikes
but Linus you might say I don't need
epic or ultra settings they don't even
look that much better and you're right
we've even got an entire video about why
it's kind of pointless to turn the
slider all the way to the max but here's
the thing even if trying to fully future
proof is foolish I'm not talking about
some hypothetical future need here if
your card isn't equipped for Ultra today
how do you think it's gonna fare in two
or three years when Ultra is the new
medium not good you know it is good
though our new stick locks joystick
covers who needs your sticks getting
knocked around when your console your
controller is in your bag check them out
at lttstore.com
with that out of the way if we look
purely at today's performance compared
to the rest of nvidia's lineup the 46
DTI looks like a pretty decent buy it
costs 40 percent less than the RTX 4070
while being only about 20 slower except
in The Last of Us probably because of
that vram issue with that said that
might be more to do with how bad the
4070 is if we add some inconvenient
truths to our numbers here the picture
gets a little less Rosy AMD has made
some very aggressive price cuts to their
last gen and the 6700 XT performs nearly
as well sometimes even beating the 4060
TI all while costing about 50 less and
while including 12 gigabytes of vram
without a hundred dollar up charge so if
all you care about is Pure rasterized
Performance per dollar you should
probably be making the switch to team
red
that being said there is an efficiency
story here that we're going to get into
later first I want to talk about higher
resolution gaming because even if Nvidia
isn't talking about it because only Ray
tracing exists for them now this is a
very solid 1440p rasterized gaming card
most games had one percent lows that
were either close to or above 60 FPS at
ultra settings with Ray tracing and dlss
off meaning that on a 60hz monitor you
can expect a consistently smooth gaming
experience want even more frames hey
just enable dlss or turn down your
settings to a more modest preset and
you're Off to the Races 1440p is just
such a great middle ground it offers a
much Sharper Image compared to 1080p
assuming the same screen size but
without the same Major Performance hit
that comes with 4K and it also comes
with this message from our sponsor
pulseway managing it systems can be a
pain but with pulse waves remote
monitoring and management software it's
a breeze you get real-time system
monitoring instant alerts and audio
remediation all from one platform at any
time using any device start your free
trial today with the link down below
speaking of 4K you can but shouldn't
some of our results were okay and if
you've got a nice 4K TV nearby or a
secondary 4k monitor depending on the
game and settings you could expect
anywhere as high as 68 FPS average in
Forza Horizon 5 with even Ray tracing
staying playable to as low as 11 FPS in
cranked out cyberpunk
games though who needs them right
blender loves Nvidia and if we only look
at this productivity Benchmark the 4060
TI slots in exactly where you'd expect
we take a closer look at say DaVinci
Resolve with av1 h.264 and h.265 well
now we're losing to not only several AMD
cards but sometimes Intel's Arc a770 and
this one Hurts the Most even the 3060 TI
and the worst part is this isn't
isolated digging into our spec view perf
benchmarks the 6700 XT and the 3060 TI
often come out ahead or basically on par
with nvidia's new hotness but why
okay while I often say that the specs
for a GPU don't matter what matters is
the performance sometimes the
performance makes no sense and we've got
to dig into the specs to find out why
the 4060 TI is based on an 8106 die that
boosts up to 2.5 gigahertz with 4352
Cuda cores 136 4th gen tensor cores and
34 3rd gen Ray tracing course all of
which sounds sufficiently next gen what
doesn't is that the eight gigs of vram
that we've talked about so much already
is on a 128-bit bus compared to the 3060
TI which had double that that is a major
cost cutting measure that seems to have
significantly harmed the 4060 TI in
memory intensive applications for
context guys back in the 600 series days
you had to go all the way down to the
650 TI which cost 150 dollars to find
such a budget conscious memory interface
but to nvidia's credit cheap bastards
that they are you can't ignore how well
it kept up the majority of the time and
according to Nvidia this is largely
thanks to the 4060 TI's massively
upgraded cash they claim and our numbers
do bear this out that it improves
performance reduces latency and
increases power efficiency so yeah a
narrow bus does limit data transfer
speeds to vram and in a perfect world we
wouldn't have to give that up but the
more we can store in the cash instead of
vram the better now I'm not a GPU
architect so I can't say this for
certain but it seems like this trade-off
might be contributing to better
performance in hybrid applications like
gaming while also taking advantage of
the 4060 TI's Ray tracing course and its
AI engine I mean looking at performance
in games with Ray tracing it's clear
that this isn't some feature that's
tacked on now it's actually usable and
unless you have six hundred dollars to
blow on a 4070 this is the best next-gen
gaming experience on the Block and the
same goes for when we turn on dlss AI
upscaling which in general turns
playable into smooth and smooth into
smooth leader you isn't perfect there
are still some visual anomalies from
time to time and we did find outliers
where performance did not improve for
example using dlss3 and returnal
resulted in a degraded experience
whether we had frame generation enabled
or not so super bizarre but it has
improved to the point where some games
not only look the same and perform
better but will even look better with
dlss it's definitely a nice to have
and what makes it even better is that
the 4060 TI draws significantly less
power than its predecessor sometimes
staying within 140 Watts depending on
the gamer workload that is really
impressive and could even be the
difference between needing to upgrade
your power supply or not needing to
upgrade your power supply this part's
anecdotal we're still waiting on our
Sound Chamber but in terms of Acoustics
while gaming it's no louder than really
any other card which is good I guess
considering that it only reaches 66
degrees on average during our f-122 loop
with a Max temp of 79 on The Hot Spot
we're going to have way more concrete
testing on GPU noise and thermals down
the line so make sure you stay tuned for
more Labs updates
so then at four hundred dollars is it a
good product at a good price
let me put it this way when Nvidia CEO
Jensen told all of his Pascal gamer
friends that it's safe to upgrade now it
wasn't 3060s and 3060 TI's might as well
have been made of unobtainium but now
honestly yeah I agree the only question
is whether it's safe to upgrade to
Nvidia the 40 series is already a mixed
bag and now the 4060 family looks like
it's going to be similarly all over the
map at 300 the non-ti version could make
sense but then if these specs are
anything to go by you're going to be
leaving a lot of performance on the
table then at 400 we've got good
performance but do you really want to
hamstring yourself with only eight gigs
of RAM and then 500 I mean gee that's an
awful lot of money to spend on an
entry-class Cheapo 128 bit GPU that's
masquerading as a performance to your
card it seems like Nvidia has just
completely decoupled their manufacturing
costs from their retail price here look
no further and the 100 up charge for 20
bucks of memory so if I was a cynic
and I am I would say that the pricing
structure here is just a way of
manufacturing fomo so that you'll upsell
yourself to spend more than maybe you
should thankfully though we do still
have some competition in the space
power consumption Ray tracing and dlss
aren't major concerns for you the 6700
XT from AMD is a compelling option with
more rumored to be coming and this one
was a big shocker Arc actually put up a
pretty decent fight today especially if
you consider the 350 price and
especially if you consider our sponsor
gorgeous gorgeous help desk is a
customer support platform that aims to
revolutionize the way that businesses
interact with their customers their
single unified dashboard makes staying
organized simpler than ever we've even
utilized gorgeous on ltcstore.com to
help with our customer support a big
part of why it's a lot better lately a
big part of that decision was how easy
it is to integrate gorgeous with
platforms like Shopify and Facebook as
the business grows so does their need
for efficient and effective customer
support and gorgeous can come in clutch
with their automated systems as well as
their insight and analytics tools and
since everything is centralized you can
respond to customer inquiries via email
chat and social media messages without
drowning in a sea of chrome tabs our
switch to gorgeous help desk was simple
pain-free and it fit our customer
support needs it's certainly been easier
to provide customers with fast and
personalized support so see if they can
help you too by checking out gorgeous at
the link down below if you guys liked
this video make sure to check out our
4090 coverage it's super expensive but
it's a really impressive card